you
ready all right come on now brother how
you doing man what's going on man how
are you all right all right welcome to
the P thank you I appreciate it thank
you for uh having me uh this is dope man
uh just a little bit about me just real
quick um 25 I grew up in church all my
life my parents were pastor and first
lady all my life literally and I
actually PK brother PK and uh I'm from
Detroit Michigan okay okay yep and uh
funny thing is even though I've been
raised in church all my life I actually
just found Christ or received Christ as
my Lord and Savior actually just ate
months ago praise God so it's kind of
weird you know how that happens but you
know God be the glory um yeah yeah um I
grew up in uh uh I I'm not sure if you
heard of coic Church of God in Christ
yeah yeah I grew up in that uh
organization and
um I just just real quick about tongues
you know what I mean I've been reading
up on it I have a John MacArthur Study
Bible
ESV okay secessionist yeah he's a
secessionist exactly so that's why I'm
really you know confused about you know
a cessationist and a continuist right um
if you don't mind uh expounding on that
what is exactly a secession because I
tried to look it up a little bit and
yeah yeah John MacArthur he's a reformed
calvinist but he's a Baptist who
believes that the signs gifts meaning
speaking in tongues and healings and
miracles were for the first century
Church to establish the church and once
it's established those gifts are not
necessary or needed anymore right and he
applies it to his interpretation 1
Corinthians 138 to13 which we went
through and it's a misinterpretation it
that's not it doesn't say what he says
now there are other reformed Calvinists
reformed Christians not all reformed
Christians are Calvinists but reformed
Christians that believe these gifts are
still operative and normative meaning
the holy spirit will still give people
the ability to speak in tongues
languages and people to interpret them
as well as to be able to heal but it
doesn't mean that everyone who claims to
have that gift actually has that gift so
those are the perspectives in
Christianity absolutely two perspec so
you have someone named Sam storms who's
reformed if I my memory doesn't fail me
and he believes the gifts are still with
us until Christ returns so not all
reformed Christians are
secessionists right and there are
evangelicals who are not reform they are
secessionists so for example the late
Norman Geisler who was a theological
Beast brilliant man of God who went to
be the Lord he wasn't a calvinist he
wasn't reformed but he was a
secessionist okay so this is a debate
among Christians now my understanding it
I'm not infallible I went from you know
I went back and forth because I was RA
raised among independent fundamental
Baptists and they are
anti-s fundamental Baptists anti-s and
this particular group they're King James
only so I was taught these gifts are not
part of the church and those who speak
in tongues they are doing so by the
devil but as I grew and I studied I went
back and forth and all I can say right
now if I follow the scriptures and I
interpret them correctly there's nothing
in the scriptures that you can point to
to say those gifts were the for the
first
and they're done away with that's all I
can say I agree I agree from my studies
even though I've you know like I said
John mccarthur Study Bible I was looking
at what he was saying I'm like just
doesn't make sense and when you you
talked about it earlier not too too long
ago about 30 minutes ago about uh when
the perfect comes and you kind of
expounded on that and I was just looking
at it this morning I'm like yeah it's
making sense yeah that made sense you
know 178 tells you what the perfect is
because if we follow John MacArthur if
the perfect means the Canon scripture
well number one right the Canon wasn't
fully recognized until the 4th Century
so even if I follow his argument if I
don't have the knowledge of what the
Canon is that means those gifts will
still be with the Christians until
there's a full recognition of the Canon
right well that didn't take place till
the 4th Century that means even
according to MacArthur's standard that
means the gifts were still operative for
300 years that's number two the problem
with saying it's the Canon it says when
the perfect comes we will know fully we
will see clearly not dimly we will
know has that happened to anybody no sir
so it cannot refer to the Canon because
instead of the Canon bringing greater
unity and Clarity there's greater
Division disunity and there's no one on
this side of glor that can say now I see
clearly not dimly through a mirror and
now I fully know as I'm fully known that
has not happen so what's the perfect 1
Corinthians 1 78 says you lack no
charismatic gifts it even uses the word
charismatic gifts until the revelation
of the Lord Jesus Christ meaning when he
comes he perfects
us awesome thank you for uh saying that
that was awesome that was beautiful um
and then real quick I did ask about
tongues a little bit more specifically I
do believe of course all the gifts still
exist and are still active today but is
there any um cuz you know like I said
I've ra I've been raised in this
organization and I'm just trying to
understand it completely um is it
because then again you know John
MacArthur he talks about you know tongue
tongue and tongues are two different
thing right uh tongues
and I'm sorry I don't mean to cut you
off you can use the term tongue as a
collective singular when you speak of
speaking in a tongue obviously meaning
you're speaking a specific language but
even the Singler in the Bible that's how
the Bible Works Singler can refer to a
collective whole so I'm referring to all
the
parts together as a whole that's why I
use the singular when I say the body of
Christ it's one right okay yeah yeah
Bible says that body of Christ consists
of churches multiple or the Church of
Christ and churches of so in other words
the Bible will use the singular for the
collective whole for its manifold part
so that's not a good argument but if
you're asking me does the word tongue in
Greek mean language yeah it means
language right but the real question is
does that mean it's speaking only of
human languages no because if you go to
1 Corinthians 13 right and if you read
verse one and two if you read
specifically 1 Corinthians 13:1 it says
if I speak the language of men and
angels but I do not have love right what
does it say if I speak the tongues of
men so that means even angels have a
language and the Holy Spirit can enable
you to speak the language of angels not
just humans
wow that's what's called The Heavenly
language
gotta that's
good that's it thank you that's awesome
that's awesome that's awesome thank you
I appreciate that I'm I'm not I'm not
too familiar with you sir I've seen in
the chat your name is Sam but definitely
I've seen your videos pop up on my feed
a whole lot I just haven't clicked it
I'm a firefighter I hear that talk all
the time at work so I Ain it ain't that
bad ain't that I need you come I'll make
you a mod shoot I
need uh thanks you guys I appreciate it
man uh uh real quick I I've seen you
have a study Bible before uh in one
video yeah yeah Avery what what Study
Bible do you use sir well yeah it's I
have have a few but the one that you saw
on video was of MacArthur Study Bible
okay okay but but that was when like you
know I I didn't I didn't know MacArthur
was a sensationalist or stuff like that
because there I don't agree with
everything he says in his commentary you
know absolutely there's a lot of things
he does say that you know make sense and
it's a good breakdown but there's
certain things that I'm like yeah nah
absolutely yeah I I had a conversation
with a friend of mine he's like yeah you
should throw that Bible I'm like well I
don't know if I should throw it away
it's good see
you know figure out some things between
this one and this one you know and
understand some things CU I would never
I would have never thought what a
cessationist is or whatever if it wasn't
for this so ex absolutely man one thing
I want to give you advice brother uh yes
sir it's always dangerous like even with
me this why I tell people you have to
seek the holy spirit to guide you into
the fullness of Truth Because unless you
think you have perfect theology which
would be arrogance and satanic none of
us have now I don't know where my
theology is wrong because if I knew it I
would discard it so when I say something
because I believe it's true the danger
with a commentary by one individual
you're trusting that one person's
understanding of what the passage so
just like you're taking my word for it
but see this the thing I think I'm right
until I'm convinced I'm wrong and I
think the other guy's wrong until I'm
convinced he's right the danger with
going with one Study Bible one
individual you're dependent on that
person and his understanding of a
collection of books
now unless he has infallible knowledge
or he's inspired you can't take just one
person's explanation of the entire Bible
because he doesn't have that kind of
knowledge to be able to be certain to
tell you that he understands the Bible
as a whole that's why we look to a
collective body of Sanctified Minds
filled with the spirit to see what this
group throughout the ages have taught
about scripture and we trust the spirit
then to guide us in the fullness of the
truth amen amen
thank you I appreciate you guys I think
I'm good I don't want to waste too much
time either let somebody else get in
here hey man thank you guys I appreciate